the European Union has recommended
suspending 7.5 billion euros in funds to
Hungary over corruption allegations
Hungarian prime minister Victor Orban is
accused of mismanaging EU funds and
dismantling Democratic institutions the
monies intended to bring hungary's
economy and infrastructure up to the
Block's standards the suspension must be
approved by a majority of EU member
states within three months
for more Let's cross over to DW
correspondent Terry Schultz in Brussels
Terry you know some of this isn't new
the European commission has been
accusing Hungarian prime minister Victor
Orban of dismantling Democratic
institutions for nearly a decade now why
this decision only now
that's certainly true the allegations
against prime minister Orban on
corruption specifically are definitely
not new in fact the eu's anti-fraud
office investigated how Hungary spent EU
funds from 2015 to 2019 and found that
four percent of that money had
irregularities tied to its spending so
this is certainly something the
commission has wanted to get a handle on
for a long time what has changed and
what is new today is their ability to do
this and that's because a mechanism
created in 2020 was challenged in court
by Hungarian Poland who figured they
would be among the first targets of it
and in fact that was only confirmed the
legality of it in February of this year
so that's the mechanism that the
European commission is using now to try
to withhold money from the eu's general
budget now there has been another effort
to keep money from Hungary over its its
rule of law and and Corruption
allegations from the commission and that
is by withholding approval of hungary's
recovery budget for covid measures and
that's a six billion dollar fund so
that's been held up as well over these
corruption charges but this certainly
seems to have struck a court in Budapest
struck a court in Budapest how has
Budapest been reacting to this
that's right the Hungarian government
knew this was coming and in recent days
it suggested that it would change its
laws and put in place some more
anti-corruption measures to bring itself
into compliance with what it believes
the commission wants from it and they
said that these laws would be passed the
middle of November so certainly it
remains to be seen if that goes through
EU member countries have yet to Castle
their votes as you well know so what
happens now
that's right this will go to EU heads of
state and government now and the
commissioner commissioner Han today gave
Hungary two months to change its laws to
prove he said that it was going to
improve its performance in rule of law
before the the EU heads of state would
have to make a decision they've got
three months to make that move and
Hungary has said this will be in place
in two months so really it will be a bit
of a waiting game and I'm certainly
certain that we'll see a lot of politics
on this move play out before that
Terry Schultz on top of Affairs in
Brussels as always many thanks